[Musique]
on nous vole entier on constate
aujourd'hui une influence d'un certain
nombre de pays étrangers sur le monde
académique et dans les universités
c'est vrai en australie qui a constaté
que la chine prenait une place
extrêmement importante beaucoup
d'étudiants chinois se livrent à des
actions d'influencé des actions
d'ingérence dans le monde universitaire
même chose en grande-bretagne même chose
dans un certain nombre de pays européens
donc le sénat a voulu se pencher sur ce
sujet examiner ce qui en était sur le
territoire national français
combien pu constater c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il ya des dispositifs
extrêmement puissant qui sont mis en
oeuvre par les pays qui ne partagent pas
nos valeurs démocratiques je veux parler
de la russie je parlais de la turquie où
je parlais de la chine qui se livrent à
ces ingérences et ses influences la
chine à travers des instituts situe
confucius la turquie on à repérer toute
une série d'interventions
de pression sur un certain nombre de
chercheurs qui travaillent sur chipait
qui travaillent bien sûr sur génocide
arménien et sur lesquels devaient
recteur pressions s'exercent mettant à
mal la liberté de chercher la liberté de
penser ce qu'on appelle les libertés
académiques dans votre pays
[Musique]
je crois d'abord qu'il faut savoir ce
qui se passe et d'observer de près ce
rapport c'est un rapport d'alerté de ce
rapport d' alerte et bien nous
escomptons une vigoureuse politique du
gouvernement il faut que nos universités
soient sensibilisés mais il faut aussi
qu'elle soit protégée un institut
confucius qui s'installe dans une
université il est censé enseigner la
langue chinoise et les sens et faire la
promotion ou faire connaître la culture
chinoise ce qui est une bonne chose mais
d'ici à se livrer à des ingérences ou à
vouloir influencer nos politiques
universitaires parfois à vouloir capter
un certain nombre de données de
recherche scientifique dé tout le monde
est à grosse différence donc il faut
être sensible au sujet il faut pas être
naïf il faut pas être candidat quand de
ses libertés essentielles que pratique
la france
ressortent des influences des
exagérations
ou des ingérences très dur dans
l'université il faut y mettre un terme